I think there's a scientist in everyone
and everyone should learn some science
the first is because then you get to
understand the world better and what's
happening around you and how beautiful
life and the world is and magical and
that's by learning something about
science and the second thing I wish
people would learn is the way scientists
think there's sort of a scientific way
of thinking and of attacking problems
and so we scientists attack scientific
problems with the sort of analytical
logical thinking but I use because I've
been trained as a scientist that's how I
attack all the problems in my life it's
how I decide how I make decisions it's
how I decide what I'm gonna buy it's how
I decide whether or not information
that's being provided to me is correct
or not and I think I'm pretty good at it
right and so I like to not be afraid of
the world I like to think that I can
reason my way out of any predicament or
make a good decision so that I can live
a happier life and that comes from like
learning this sort of scientific way of
thinking and it's just a fun way to
approach the world because then I'm not
anybody at anybody's whim except my own
and I think that's a wonderful way to
live
you